[موسيقى]
بعد ان ظهر ملف التسفير وبدات الايقافات
في صفوف حركه النهضه في قيدات حركه النهضه
وغيرها من الرؤوس التي
ستفتح باب جهنم على العديد من الرؤوس في
كامل اجهزه الدوله
كانت هناك عمليه كبيره من اجل التخلص من
رئيس الجمهوريه قيس سعيد الذين يحملونه
فتح هذا الملفات يحملونه مسؤوليه فتح هذه
الملفات
واكيد انهم
من اجل التخلص منه قاموا
بتخطيط والتامر على امن الدوله من اجل
التخلص من هذا
الرئيس ومنه خاصه من نظام الذي
تحصلنا عليه والنظام الجديد بعد الثوره
الشعبيه التي حدثت في 25 جويليه 2021
والتي اخرجتهم من الحكم واخرجت كل مافيا
الفساد من من قوقعتها
فخططوا للعوده
وارادوا العوده بكل السبل بكل السبل سواء
سياسيه او حتى معناها بطرق التي تهدد امن
القومي وكان السيناريوات مخيفه كانت تخطط
لتونس ولكن
المخابرات والعديد من الامنيين الشرفاء
قاموا باحباط هذا المخطط
واعتقال او ايقاف كل المتورطين في هذا
المخطط
نحن لسنا نعيش في حاله فوضى السياسيه
العكس تماما نحن هنا في بدايه لترسيخ دوله
القانون لانه فتحت كل الملفات لا احد فوق
المحاسبه بدات المحاسبه
وتم تغيير النظام الانتخابي والنظام
السياسي عبر اللجوء الى الشعب عبر استفتاء
نجح الاستفتاء هناك العديد من من الذين
قاطعوا الاستفتاء اكيد لكن القانون لم
يحرمهم من
ان يكونوا موجودين او ان يدلبوا اصواتهم
او ان يترشحوا هم خيروا عدم الترشح او عدم
القيام
بواجبهم الوطني هم مسؤولين على ذلك لكن كل
ما حدث في تونس دون ان تسيل قطر الدم
واحده قمنا بالتخلص من حكم الاخوان
بالقانون وهذا مؤشر جديد على انه
الجمهوريه الجديده ستكون جمهوريه دوله
القانون
[موسيقى]